thomas on se marie
personne te force à venir kaka est chez
moi holy ghost
envie j'ai l'impression qu'on n'avance
plus faire partie de mes n'apprécie pas
difficile
j'ai pas encore rockwell ça fait un an
qu'elle m'a quittée en fait y'a votre
bébé tombé dessus avec mister bell et je
sais pas comment ça marche moralement ça
marche pas du tout à cet âge-là je vais
pas les mains là dedans moi je suis
désolé je peux rien faire pour toi ça
c'est la rolls avec ça tu chopes la
jeune maman divorcée sexuellement aller
loin fin c'est pas de ma faute si les
femmes n'est pas pas de piquer un bébé
pour aller voir ma tâche et nice thomas
ça me fait bizarre de voir je
m'attendais pas et c'est à toi oui mais
quel âge il a enfin oui ça me fait
bizarre de voir
oui ça me fait bizarre qui était un bébé
dans les bras il s'appelle comment
claude bébé mais tu as toujours pas la
tête d'accor à bbb tu ne prêteras se
balade s'est pas jouée voilà dans
confiance là et là tu donnes et là c'est
beau la ja du geste
ça va tu vas trop loin et lui la vérité
oktar est de faire n'importe quoi est ce
bébé et sa mère marie parce que tu vas
finir pour leur faire du mal à qui tu
débarques avec ton fils après tu me dis
qu séparer vois tu cherches trois
membres
le narguer et d'une drague et
des petites courses quoi